el primer ministro son castex anunció la
suspensión de vuelos o con brasil hasta
nueva orden francia había mantenido
algunos vuelos entre ambos países con un
protocolo sanitario reforzado como la
presentación de un test psr negativo de
menos de 72 horas pero para muchos en
especial los diputados de oposición esta
era una medida que no era suficiente
además había que tener en cuenta la
situación sanitaria de brasil que cada
día viene agravándose además de esto se
suma la preocupación de los médicos
franceses por esta variante brasilera
llamada p 1 según un estudio realizado
por la asociación brasilera de cuidados
intensivos y que publicó los resultados
hace unos días pues esta variante es
mucho más contagiosa afecta más a los
jóvenes y puede ser resistente a las
vacunas los médicos en francia temen a
pesar de que esta variante por ahora
representa sólo el 5% de los contagios
actualmente pues que llegue a una cuarta
ola de contagios mucho más letal que la
que se está viviendo actualmente por
cuenta de la variante británica